[Musica]
[Applauso]
era un tardo pomeriggio di fine estate
uno di quei tiepidi momenti che ti
potevi ancora godere quando il clima non
aveva presentato il conto cioè questa
deriva attuale con i cambiamenti
climatici che vediamo negli ultimi anni
negli ultimi decenni
io ero un bambino avrò avuto 10 anni e
stavo tornando me né verso il casolare
dove passavo alcune settimane in estate
lungo un viottolo di campagna
ero assorto nei miei pensieri è così
però pensavo alle mie cose ma è come
sempre succede in questi casi la realtà
irrompe immediatamente e ti fa saltare
perché a un certo punto mi ritrovai in
mezzo a una enorme nuvola di farfalline
che volavano e non era raro vedere
qualche farfallina zig zagare lungo
questi viottoli di campagna ma una cosa
di questo tipo poteva addirittura far
paura in realtà non ero intimorito da
quasi stupito da questa scena surreale
tanto che per rendermi conto di cosa
succedeva ho fatto un paio di passi
indietro per vedere quanto era grande
questa nuvola no e in quel momento ho
visto una scena che sarebbe rimasta
sempre indelebile nella mia mente per
tutti gli anni della mia vita fino ad
oggi sui lati del diotto c'era una rete
una sorta di zanzariera con maglie un po
più grandi e in mezzo alla rete
incastrata una farfalla non si capiva
come si fosse incastrata così però
insomma al di là di cercare le ragioni
ho detto qui bisogna fare assolutamente
qualcosa sono corso verso casa che
fortunatamente era a poche centinaia di
metri ho preso una forbicina sono
tornato rapidamente ii e con la fortuna
degli audaci ma anche con la vista da
falco che avevo quella volta sono
riuscito a tagliare un paio di maglie
vicino a questa rete è sostanzialmente
senza fare danno al corpo della farfalla
la o liberata e così contento e
felicemente tornavo a casa rimuginando
queste parole una rete una farfalla una
rete una farfalla ma come voi sapete
ognuno di noi dà un significato diverso
le parole a seconda della propria
l'udienza è bene da quel momento per me
la rete è diventato un simbolo di
oppressione e la farfalla invece il
simbolo della libertà incondizionata e
quindi da quel momento ho pensato
veramente che per essere veramente
libero si doveva fare come la farfalla
cioè isolarsi da tutti e da tutto volare
libera e felice fare come un eremita
poi piano piano piano piano sono
cresciuto e sono venuto in contatto con
alcuni pensatori e soprattutto con uno
di questi questo signore che vedete qua
cartesio che per me era un po il teorico
della libertà incondizionata per che
cosa faceva cartesio sostanzialmente
divideva divideva il mondo in due grandi
settori lares cogitans da una parte e la
resistenza dall'altra quindi la cosa
pensante l'uomo ovviamente con la sua
intelligenza che trascendeva e poteva
dominare la natura perché dall'altra
parte c'era la res extensa che era la
natura intesa come inerte e plasmabile a
piacere quindi capite la mia idea di
libertà cominciò a cambiare un po cioè
non è essere libero non vuol dire
soltanto svolazzare liberamente ma anche
interagire con la natura perché tu in
qualche modo puoi fare quello che vuoi
della natura perché la natura non ha una
dinamica e inerte non risponde alle tue
azioni e allora vedete sulla base di
questa concezione è nato lo sviluppo di
tutte le società soprattutto accidentali
il capitalismo occidentale ma anche il
socialismo reale ha sempre pensato che
la natura fosse qualcosa da cui
attingere delle risorse e in cui gettare
dei rifiuti perché tanto non c'è nessun
problema la natura non risponde puoi
fare quello che vuoi poi piano piano
ancora sono cresciuto e sono venuto in
contatto col mondo scientifico che poi è
il mondo di cui mi occupo adesso
sostanzialmente e allora i primi ad
accorgersi che questa cosa non è una
vera cioè che la natura non è inerte
plasmabile a piacere sono stati gli
ecologi grazie mi direte allo scoperto
l'acqua calda tutti lo sanno che gli
animali hanno una dinamica lo sappiamo
anche noi quando accarezziamo un gatto o
facciamo le coccole un cane in casa
nostra ma qui in realtà c'era qualcosa
di più cioè gli ecologi hanno scoperto
che per vivere le specie devono essere
in interazione tra loro e in particolare
gli ecologi matematici hanno scoperto
delle cose molto interessanti per
esempio c'è un modellino molto semplice
che lega la numerosità del di una specie
che viene chiamata preda che per noi
saranno dei conigli e una specie che
viene chiamata predatore che per noi
saranno delle volpi allora l'idea è
quella che i conigli anno abbondante
erba da mangiare e crescono inizialmente
in maniera indefinita poi però le volpi
cominciano a mangiare i conigli quindi
crescono le volpi ma i conigli
cominciano a diminuire
ma quando diminuisce la popolazione di
conigli le volpi hanno meno da mangiare
quindi cominciano a riprodursi di meno
ea diminuire ancora loro ma questo punto
i conigli prosperano perché ci sono meno
volpi e ricominciano a salire quindi
vedete c'è una sorta di ciclo
indefinito nelle popolazioni di volpi e
conigli ma c'è un equilibrio natura
diciamo così ma e se noi fossimo le
volpi cosa potrebbe succedere
e perché noi abbiamo sempre delle
furbate noi con il nostro in genio ci
inventiamo delle cose allora guardate
cosa potrebbe succedere una cosa di
questo tipo che nel momento in cui noi
vediamo che i co ni ti stanno diminuendo
drasticamente e diciamo caspita ma qua e
bisogna fare qualcosa perché non
inventiamo il fucile e così ne
ammazziamo di più ok però se alla fine
li ammazziamo tutti i conigli si
estinguono ma dopo si estingue anche ci
estinguiamo anche noi volpi ora è chiaro
questo è un modellino estremamente
semplice no ci sono più specie in natura
però è interessante capire che c'è una
relazione diretta tra le specie cioè le
specie in qualche modo
sono interrelate insomma non sono
indipendenti l'una dall'altra ecco che
comincia a cambiare l'idea di libertà
insomma no perché io in qualche modo
devo correll armi con queste cose allora
in qualche modo
questo vale per le specie viventi ma in
realtà io poi sono diventato uno
scienziato del clima io dico sempre con
un po di presupponenza e non forse noi
senza di del clima abbiamo fatto
qualcosa di più perché ok la natura
animata a una dinamica ma quelle
inanimata
allora cosa abbiamo scoperto chi si
sarebbe mai immaginato che l'aria
dell'atmosfera e l'acqua degli oceani
avrebbe risposto alle nostre azioni in
maniera così importante come ha fatto
voi sapete per esempio noi cosa facciamo
al clima sostanzialmente bruciano
combustibili fossili carbone petrolio
gas naturale tutte le volte che bruciano
combustibili fossili dalla reazione
chimica di combustione esce la co2 la
famosa anidride carbonica poi produciamo
anche altri gas in altro modo defoe
restiamo quindi togliamo di mezzo degli
assorbitori di anidride carbonica che
sono gli alberi insomma facciamo
dell'agricoltura non sostenibile in
tutto questo cosa succede che la
temperatura media terrestre nell'ultimo
secolo è aumentata di circa un grado voi
direte e poco in qualche modo
effettivamente la dinamica naturale è
più lenta della dinamica umana ma
attenzione perché può diventare quasi
inesorabile nel senso che quando tu hai
aumentato di un grado quasi la
temperatura dell'acqua degli oceani è
difficilissimo tornare indietro noi
questa temperatura ce la terremo per
centinaia di anni
e così via
allora vedete l'idea è che noi facciamo
qualcosa la natura e la natura
cambia il suo stato per quello che
abbiamo fatto noi ma vediamo le cose più
in maniera specifica dove siamo noi
nella natura noi siamo lan troposfera
quindi la sfera umana
quegli altri pezzi che vedete in giro
sono la rappresentazione dei singoli
pezzi del sistema clima l'atmosfera i
mari la criosfera cioè i ghiacci la
biosfera cioè la materia vivente insomma
e poi da una parte ci sono anche gli
influssi naturali sul clima dovuti a
fattori astronomici alla terra solida da
cui escono i vulcani e così via allora
vedete che dall antroposfera escono
delle frecce sostanzialmente due una che
sono le emissioni di co2 viene di ri
carbonica e di altri gas e l'altra che è
il cattivo uso del suolo cioè la
deforestazione
il fatto di fare un agricoltura
sostenibile e così via
ora cosa succede però vedete queste
frecce vanno in giro in tutto il sistema
è però nella troposfera entrano a loro
volta delle frecce e quali sono queste
frecce sono le risposte del sistema
clima a quello che abbiamo fatto noi
quindi vedete il sistema trima e noi
siamo altamente
interrelati correlati e allora abbiamo
un problema non sta aumentando la
temperatura del pianeta cosa crea questo
crea innalzamento del livello dei mari
fusione dei ghiacci lo vediamo con i
nostri ghiacciai alpini crea un crea il
fatto che siamo in preda alle siccità
che siamo in balia degli eventi estremi
delle alluvioni lampo dei chicchi di
grandine grossi come palle da tennis e
così via siamo in balia in qualche modo
anche delle migrazioni che sono dovute
al cambiamento climatico perché nove
migranti su dieci di quelli che arrivano
in italia con i barconi fuggono
certamente dalle guerre ma anche da un
fenomeno molto importante che si chiama
desertificazione allora vedete dobbiamo
fare qualcosa ne va
tutto sommato della nostra sopravvivenza
e allora anche qui entra il gene umano
ma attenzione
rischiamo di fare una furbata come
quella del fucile
lo sapete che qualcuno vuole accendere
un'altra freccia dall antroposfera verso
il sistema clima perché
sappiamo che quando erutta un grande
vulcano queste polveri si mettono in
atmosfera e fanno da schermo alla luce
solare ne arriva di meno a terra la
terra si scalda di meno riscalda di meno
l'atmosfera sovrastante allora cosa
succede
diminuisce un po la temperatura allora
c'è qualcuno che dice ma tasti da
facciamo una furbata perché non spariamo
delle polveri come se fossero polveri
vulcaniche in atmosfera così in qualche
modo controbilanciano l'aumento di
temperatura dovuta all'emissione delle
carbonica e altri gas e aumento della
polvere invece porterebbe a ridurre
l'atmosfera allora possiamo bloccare
l'aumento di temperatura è certo ammesso
e non concesso che noi siamo sempre in
grado di sparare polveri in atmosfera
perché non c'è una crisi economica non
c'è una guerra eccetera eccetera
eccetera
ammesso e non concesso che queste
polveri non facciano male alla salute
certo noi potremmo bloccare l'aumento di
temperatura
ma attenzione questa è una soluzione
semplice come quella del fucile che poi
porta però altri danni qui in
particolare viene sconvolto il ciclo
dell'acqua allora i nostri modelli ci
fanno vedere che si tutto sommato la
temperatura potremmo fermarla ma
interi subcontinenti diventerebbero dei
deserti dove non pioverà più dovremmo
spostare centinaia di milioni di persone
perché lì non si può più vivere
insomma sostanzialmente un disastro
allora vedete perché un disastro perché
questa e vuole essere una soluzione
semplice a un problema complesso cosa
dobbiamo fare noi invece con quelle
frecce ve lo lascio pensare e
sicuramente tutti voi riuscirete a
capire come noi dobbiamo queste frecce
che noi abbiamo aumentato enormemente
dobbiamo riportarlo indietro dobbiamo
rallentare le nostre emissioni di gas
serra la nostra deforestazione fare
un'agricoltura più forza e mi bile e
così via perché vedete il clima non è
partito per la tangente è ancora tutto
sommato in equilibrio quindi se noi
tiriamo il freno effettivamente possiamo
fermarla e allora cosa vuol dire questo
significa che noi siamo un nodo della
rete ea questo dobbiamo pensare cioè non
pensare in questa idea di libertà
che è voluta dentro di me in varia
maniera eccetera eccetera a questo punto
è diventata questa cioè noi siamo un
nodo della rete noi dobbiamo cercare di
armonizzare la nostra dinamica con
quella della natura perché anche la
natura una dinamica e ci risponde e lo
vediamo ma quindi io credo veramente che
la parola magica sia armonia cioè andare
ad armonizzare la nostra dinamica con
quella della natura e allora e allora la
mia idea di libertà non è più quella di
quando ero bambino non è quella della
farfalla che si libera in aria
assolutamente indipendente da tutto non
è quella di fare quello che vuoi la
natura perché sappiamo quali sono le
conseguenze
eccetera eccetera insomma io credo che
noi non siamo la farfalla siamo un nodo
della rete
nessuno è libero da solo
[Applauso]